When the Arctic Monkeys formed, none of them
could play a musical instrument.
If you ate in a different New York eatery
every day for 12 years, you still wouldn't
have visited all of the city's restaurants.
Lizards can't breathe and walk at the same
time.
Coyotes in the US have learnt how traffic
lights work so they can cross the road safely.
The world's largest container ships can carry
746 million bananas.
A quarter of American couples sleep in separate
beds.
90% of all jellyfish are smaller than a human
thumbnail.
Only two countries have not ratified the UN
Convention on the Rights of the Child: Somalia
and the US.
John Montagu the 11th and current Earl of
Sandwich runs a chain of sandwich shops called
Earl of Sandwich.
Drinking wine before a meal makes you eat
25% more.
The place where Hitler killed himself is now
a children's playground.
Barry Manilow's No. 1 hit 'I Write the Songs'
wasn't written by Barry Manilow.
In 2002, the US military developed a sandwich
that stays fresh for three years.
On 28 June 2009, Stephen Hawking hosted a
party for time travellers from the future.
Nobody showed up.
New Zealand has an official National Wizard.
In wine-tasting, a 'cat pee aroma' is a compliment.